aussi et surtout robert duvall robert
duvall qui fut pendant de très
nombreuses années le premier grand
second rôle américain devenu une vedette
à part entière depuis le parrain
sanglante profession etc etc
robert duvall est présent cette année à
cannes à double titre
et pour la première fois acteur dans
tender mercies et réalisateur de angelo
my love deux films en compétition
angelo my love c'est l'avis de la
communauté gitane aux états unis robert
duval s'est passionné pour ce sujet il a
tourné au milieu de cette communauté
sans acteurs professionnels et l'idée
que nous avons eu dès son arrivée à
cannes c'est de l'emmener avec madame
duval dans un campement de gitans juste
derrière cannes à mougins et ce court
métrage pourrait s'intituler monsieur et
madame robert duvall en liberté ont fait
le plein de chagrin
poignée de main robert connaît quelques
mots de gilles chance le contact
s'établit
non
jalouse
bon
les
pour m
non
mais selon mme du groupe city 6e et
l'autre ou dick lugar de la souris les
lovers elle est toujours à la première
duval pourquoi êtes vous intéressé
passionné par les gist ans je pense que
j'ai rencontré un jeune gitan et j'ai
fait voulu faire un film avec lui je
t'aimerai profite pour essayer de mieux
comprendre sa culture
j'ai fait le tour des états unis j'ai
rencontré des gitans rue on sait anglais
j'ai fait tout le boulot de recherche
pour intégrer les gens d'une manière
précise à travers l'univers de ce petit
garçon de sept adolescents votre
histoire c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
garçon comme celui ci ou celui là qui
vous entourent ici c'est angelo m
l'idée c'est de retrouver une bague
qu'il a volés à des gitans russe
à la fin il la retrouve retourne au
canada
mais là ils le chassent
elin junk à la fin ils se retrouvent au
mariage de son frère et ils se saoulent
il rapporte finalement cette fameuse
bague esprit je le montre aussi dans son
milieu là où ils vivent et c'est d'être
américain mais il ne peut pas la mère
lui dit et il fait comprendre tu ne peux
pas être américain et gitans à la fois
tu es seulement gitans c'était le chef
de la famille alors il reste au milieu
des siens
est-ce que les tsiganes d'amérique sont
rejetés aussi comme en europe la plupart
des américains ne connaissent même pas
les gitans ils n'ont jamais vu un gitan
grévistes en dehors les américains par
ici les gitans par là et ils font des
tas de petits boulots boulot et
cordonnier menuisier oui tout ce qu'il a
derrière moi les autres rejetées en bloc
cette histoire l'attaché de presse de
robert duvall s'impatiente mais lui
visiblement n'est plus pressés de
repartir et un des musiciens lui confie
même son bien le plus précieux
moi
nous espérons
la voix
non
bravo
aubert duval une démarche qui n'est pas
sans rappeler les sept mercenaires pour
les gitans de mougins ou de new york qui
n'est plus véritablement un gadjo vague
orange et pour terminer un coup d'oeil
sur cette exposition d'affichés